j'arrive pas à distinguer
mais rêve
de la réalité
ça doit être pénible toutes ces voix
dans sa tête
il ya du désordre endroit
accepte le
et
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à toujours debout
j'ai des troubles du sommeil
j'arrive pas à distinguer mais rêve
de la réalité bonjour et bienvenue l'a
toujours
mamad
je crois que je deviens fou
[Musique]
heureusement que tu es là quoi
tu sert vraiment à rien steve c'est
steven
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à distinguer
les vrais de la réalité
merci monsieur
j'ai perdu les lentilles de contact bon
courage merci
là
je reviens pas des vivants 4 qui
t'arrive marque
pourquoi vous m'appelez marguet
ça doit être pénible
toutes ces voix dans ta tête
[Musique]
il ya du désordre
ou à
abandonne toi au chaos
[Musique]